[Música]
gracias de nuevo secretario de estado
por esta entrevista acaba de tener una
reunión ministerial para coordinar mejor
los esfuerzos mundiales en la lucha
contra el cob el 19 porque realizar una
reunión de este tipo ahora y cuáles son
las preocupaciones que compromisos
asumidos eeuu y los otros participantes
de efectivo o bien se ha venido en
efecto acabamos de reunirnos éramos una
veintena de participantes entre ellos
francia la unión europea
a países de áfrica como sudáfrica
senegal países de todo el mundo
un grupo de liderazgo porque lo que se
necesita ahora para acabar con el
kovinic es realmente llenar los vacíos
que existen
establecimos un plan de acción muy
concreto en el que juntos identificamos
lo que falta y juntos estamos decididos
a actuar al día a utilizar las
competencias únicas de los distintos
países e instituciones para centrarnos
en donde tenemos que actuar yo
por ejemplo hemos hecho un esfuerzo
internacional muy importante para
fabricar vacunas
y ahora tenemos que asignar las mejor y
asegurarnos de que realmente lleguen a
los brazos de las personas que las
necesitan
hay un problema de resistencia de la
cadena de suministro
todo lo que se necesita para las vacunas
y su suficiencia debe ser producido y
aquí
también hay un problema de
desinformación de información falsa
vemos a personas de todo el mundo que
son susceptibles a estas desinformación
y que no se ponen estas vacunas vacunas
que están disponibles y ya pero que la
gente va a utilizar
y también existe el problema de apoyar a
los que hacen el trabajo de primera
línea
y asegurarse de que tienen lo que
necesitan para estar protegidos y por
último tenemos que construir un sistema
más eficiente para el futuro en todos
estos ámbitos tenemos seis líneas de
actuación estamos juntos para actuar
juntos porque sin esta coordinación al
final cada uno hará su tarea
pero es mucho más eficaz si se
identifican las carencias y se trabaja
conjuntamente para intentar responder a
estas
hablando de los retos que quedan en
áfrica la tasa de vacunación apenas
supera el 10% los científicos de
sudáfrica produjeron recientemente una
copia de la vacuna moderna pero hasta
que no se levanten las patentes se
retrasará mucho la vacunación en áfrica
y el fin de la pandemia mundial eeuu
está en pro de levantar las patentes que
se puede hacer mientras tanto va a haber
pronto un levantamiento de las patentes
es un trabajo que se está haciendo en
este momento y obviamente estamos a
favor
pero ya se están viendo resultados muy
importantes en áfrica cuando hay un
trabajo coordinado y concentrado
ruanda por ejemplo tenía una tasa de
vacunación en noviembre de 11 12% un
trabajo concertado con socios
internacionales y luego sobre el terreno
y ahora están en el 50 por ciento de
adultos vacunados en 6 semanas
así que es perfectamente factible cuando
se identifican lo que necesita cada país
lo que depende de cada caso y trabajamos
así que efectivamente las patentes la
producción local no sólo en eeuu o en la
india
sino la producción local es muy
importante el tema de las patentes es
muy importante sobre todo para el futuro
porque desgraciadamente sabemos que
habrá otra pandemia y debemos estar
mejor preparados y ser más eficaces pero
por el momento estamos convencidos que
con una coordinación muy exhaustiva para
cubrir las carencias existentes podemos
acabar con el 19 usted fue a daca en
senegal al instituto pasteur el pasado
mes de noviembre este instituto va a
producir vacunas contra el cob y 19 con
el apoyo de eeuu gracias a una inversión
de 3 millones de dólares puede decirnos
en qué va esta inversión
me impresionó mucho esta visita a
senegal y en el instituto pasteur
porque su pone de manifiesto no sólo la
necesidad sino la capacidad que existe
para producir a nivel nacional regional
y mundial
esto hará que esta tarea sea mucho más
eficiente en el futuro y sobre todo que
no dependamos de las cadenas de
suministro que son globales y que las
reduzcamos para asegurarnos de que en un
momento en crisis podamos tener un
impacto inmediato
el otro gran tema del momento es ucrania
varios funcionarios citados por los
medios norteamericanos en eeuu se espera
que rusia invada a ucrania el miércoles
espera usted también la invasión
lamentablemente esto es muy posible
porque el presidente putin ha puesto en
marcha todo lo que necesita para llevar
a cabo una agresión contra ucrania
vemos cada vez más fuerzas rodeando
ucrania
más de 200.000 soldados lo que es
extremadamente preocupante
incluyendo lo que está ocurriendo con el
despliegue de fuerzas bielorrusas en el
norte de ucrania
en cierto modo sería muy fácil para el
presidente indicar que está dispuesto a
seguir por la vía de la diplomacia
empezando por la reducción de las
fuerzas que rodean a ucrania sin
provocaciones no hay ninguna razón para
que rusia alturas y
la única razón que vemos es una nueva
agresión
además tenemos que ver esto en el
contexto de la historia
ya ocurrió en 2014 con una anexión de
crimea y la intervención en el este de
ucrania
así que sabiendo eso viendo lo que está
pasando alrededor del cráneo
estamos muy preocupados
perdón para que me pregunta que declara
usted dijo si es posible le hablo de una
agresión el miércoles entonces el
miércoles
si una agresión desde esta misma semana
es muy posible cuando vemos lo que está
ocurriendo alrededor de ucrania con el
despliegue de las fuerzas rusas podría
al presidente byte de viajar a ucrania a
petición del presidente ucraniano
por el momento el presidente baile está
muy comprometido con la diplomacia
hoy hablo con el presidente es el índico
antes habló con el presidente putin
estamos intentando todas las opciones
para avanzar por la vía diplomática pero
por lo pronto todo depende de rusia y
perseguirán una retirada de fuerzas de
los alrededores de ucrania para dar a la
diplomacia la oportunidad de intentar
resolver los problemas existentes o por
el contrario seguirán no sólo
manteniendo sino aumentando las fuerzas
que han desplegado en torno a ucrania y
luego actuarán con agresividad ya esta
semana
washington reveló públicamente las
intenciones de rusia incluso sus planes
hay una campaña de comunicación bastante
agresiva por parte de eeuu entonces está
en una estrategia para perturbar los
cálculos de moscú
porque la gente tiene que entender las
herramientas que los rusos en el pasado
y en la actualidad utilizan
incluida la creación de falsas
provocaciones para justificar una
intervención que ya estaba bien
planificada
esto está totalmente en su lógica y
sacar a la luz esto es una manera de
evitar ya
esta crisis no ha reforzado finalmente
los lazos entre estados unidos y los
aliados europeos que había una crisis de
confianza en eeuu al principio de la
administración baile tuvimos la retirada
de afganistán en la crisis de los
submarinos ahora tenemos la impresión de
que han recuperado las de vigilancia de
los aliados europeos
y creo que esta crisis ha reforzado
absolutamente la sólida y la
trasatlántica lo vemos cada día
es producto de desgraciadamente la
amenaza que supone una agresión rusa
pero también es producto de las intensas
consultas y coordinaciones que hemos
tenido a lo largo de varios meses
en las últimas semanas hemos sumado más
de 200 compromisos reuniones
videoconferencia
llamadas telefónicas trasatlánticas con
socios europeos con la unión europea
como tú dices todo ello creo yo no se
acercan cada vez más es un recordatorio
de los valores que compartimos abrir el
interés debemos defender
gracias
[Música]
y